[Music]
get ready because we're about to show
you some of your favorite toys you
played with in the 90s from the
mousetrap board game - dear diary and
Poochie tell us how many of these you
played with stay tuned to hear about one
of the most nostalgic games ever that no
modern kid would want to receive today
give this video a thumbs up and hit that
subscribe button to never miss another
video again now let's check out 20 toys
from the 90s no kid would want to
receive today mousetrap for game
remember this one raise your hand if you
ever played with the mousetrap board
game the rules of the game are to race
to the finish with your toy mouse the
track is located on the side of the
board game while the middle features
another playing field used to capture
the mice on the track this board game
has tons of fun contraptions and it all
starts with flushing the toilet set your
traps and watch as the small ball
travels down the contraptions to
activate the trap that captures yours
and your opponent's Mouse the winner is
the one that's able to finish the race
without getting caught doodle bears most
of the nineties kids will remember the
doodle bears but we have a feeling these
drawn on bears wouldn't be as
entertaining for kids today drawing on
bears probably not that exciting when
you have advanced technology that allows
you to draw on things and making it
disappear without a trace these bears
came in different outfits to markers and
even a sticker set that allows you to
decorate the bear the way you wanted you
are even able to throw them in the
laundry and have them washed you can
still find the Bears and plenty of
stores but we have a feeling they're
just not as popular as they were in the
90s Polly Pockets and who can possibly
forget about Polly Pockets they first
appeared in 1989 and these tiny dolls
quickly took over the world to a new age
child the thought of tiny dolls with
even tinier furniture wouldn't seem that
appealing but nineties kids will finally
remember playing with this nostalgic toy
the compact size of the toy allowed you
to carry it around practically
everywhere and you could pick from
several different universes to play with
your Polly dolls but what Polly Pockets
still be a huge thing with kids today
you probably have much better technology
to play with let us know in the comments
how many
Holle pockets you owned as a kid
Tamagotchi speaking of nostalgic toys
many of us probably played with
Tamagotchi these virtual pets seems like
something from the future but we've
already seen New Age kids react to
Tamagotchi and it really didn't go down
well it all started in 1996 in Japan and
just a year later
Tamagotchi were released in other parts
of the world these digital pets are
totally adorable the kids today might
find the interactive options a bit
limiting although Tamagotchi came back
on the scene in 2017 we feel that the
90's kids are more excited by them than
anyone else and who can blame them
Tamagotchi are awesome glitter magic one
remember this is it probably seems silly
to kids now but the glitter magic wand
was totally magical and we all wanted
one when we were kids there was just
something about watching all these
colors move from one side to the other
of course this magic wand was far from
any real toy but it was definitely
something most of the 90s kids played
with at least once in their lifetimes
and to be fair a lot of us would still
love to play with these today just for
the nostalgic effect stay tuned to see
more of your favorite 90s toys including
the doll that rocked our world
Sally Secrets do you remember when it
was all about Sally Secrets this toy
doll which first appeared in 1993 stole
the hearts of many and it's still one of
the most beloved 90 dolls ever like her
name suggests sally secrets had secrets
hitting up under her torso when you
moved her arm it revealed a bunch of
stickers he could use to play her shoes
had roller stamps that were perfect for
arts and crafts it was one of the first
toys with such practical intentions and
each one of us totally loved it her
hidden stickers and awesome roller
stamps were a perfect way to spend
quality time with your school BFF
fashion plates don't forget to tell us
how many of these nineties toys you
played with in your childhood almost
everyone will remember fashion plates
although it doesn't seem like a toy
these plates provided us with hours of
entertainment and turned us into real
time artists you were able to choose
from different hairstyles tops and even
bottoms and
plenty of different designs in just a
few seconds all you needed was to put
the plates under your paper and start
tracing fashion plates now come and
deluxe versions but nothing will compare
to that useful pink gadget
why can't Allah straighten view this
easy now that we're all adults little
miss magic jewels this doll left us all
in all as she worked her magic ninety
kids didn't even need American Girl
dolls we had little miss magic jewels
this is the doll everyone wanted when it
came out you had to use the wand and you
were able to put Jules on your doll and
everyone around you each one came with
24 jewels and you could even buy extra
packs for endless amounts of fun of
course the doll would now be considered
vintage and we have a feeling putting
jewels everywhere we get boring very
fast to kids these days but it's not
just jewels do you remember our next toy
from the same range
Little Miss magic hair maybe jewels
weren't your thing but hair most
definitely was almost every 90s girl
loved giving her dolls different
hairstyles this awesome dolls hair
changed color to rainbow the second you
brushed it pretty cool right you could
also stamp rainbow hearts on her hair
and make amazing patterns there were
several other dolls in the Little Miss
magic series but the jewels and hair
were definitely the most popular make
sure to let us know if you ever played
with or wanted to have Little Miss magic
because we sure did and we kind of still
want it now beanie babies the beanie
babies craze was huge in the 90s and
then eventually it slowly crashed as
kids started getting better toys it's
sad right beanie babies weren't only
plush toys they were also collectibles
and there were hundreds of toys to
choose from in the 90s the main beanie
babies store sold about 70 million toys
per year but the prices started to
slowly decline a beanie baby was once
worth a lot of money but at their lowest
point you can get it at the dollar store
the collectors complete list includes
hundreds of names and there are rare few
who managed to get every single beanie
baby how many did you have let us know
troll dolls troll dolls might look
totally bizarre to any child that was
born before the year 2000 but if you're
a 90s kid the color and the hair of
these dolls is totally normal everyone
at least one troll doll and we loved
playing with them the more you had the
better your games were these crazy
creatures came in different styles and
while they were relatively inexpensive
back in the day you can now actually
sell these as valuable collectibles
online if a kid ever got one of these
today we would have a feeling that's
exactly what they do and to be honest we
can't really blame them Easy Bake Oven
and here's a 90s gadget that will
definitely bring back a few memories
Easy Bake Ovens were so popular you
could find them in almost every
household they were a perfect way to
give kids some form of responsibility
and put them in charge of making cakes
and other delicious foods it was one of
those toys that was super practical and
it actually gave you a chance to bake
your favorite cakes
of course adult supervision was required
but everyone adored their first Easy
Bake Oven we have a feeling kids today
would prefer to have their cupcakes
store-bought instead of trying to make
them themselves skip it skip it recently
returns on the market but as it got
technologically improved we'll look at
the original skip at version this silly
toy was the talk of the schoolyard when
it first arrived you just had to put
your leg in the hoop make the toys spin
around you and jump over it with your
other leg it's actually a lot more
complicated than it looks
every 90s kid was happy to jump around
and count how many skips they made with
the counter the new versions light up
but modern kids weren't interested
enough to bring back this nostalgic 90s
craze and who can forget about the
skippered song baby born but if you
don't remember skip it you'll remember
baby born the baby born craze was
intense these babies have several human
functions and they were first launched
in 1991 baby born is totally realistic
in the way of books and on top of that
it comes with seven functions which
include crying drinking eating and even
wetting their diaper you have the
responsibility to act like a parent to
this baby and we have a feeling that's a
bit too much for kids today who would
want to change their toy baby's diapers
anyways well it looks like the nineties
kids definitely would Hungry Hippos if
you were a child in the
you probably released all your
aggression through Hungry Hippos this
boy comes with four toy hippos for four
players the rules are pretty simple your
hippo needs to eat as many of the balls
as possible in order to win and if
you've ever played it you know it gets
really intense you get twenty balls and
a golden marble which is worth more
points and then you fight to win by
pressing the hippos button Hungry Hippos
is the game that brings out the rage and
tantrums and younger kids and we feel
like kids today definitely wouldn't
understand the joys of this nostalgic
game Poochie who didn't want the
electronic pet that was one of the best
interactive gadgets we had in the 90s
Poochie was definitely ahead of its time
you pressed the button on the top and
little Poochie came to life it's digital
eyes closed and open it was able to move
its feet eyes and tell and it was
awesome Poochie also barked in several
songs and always got stuck in our heads
you were also able to feed him a bone
and watch him play we have a feeling
kids today would get totally creeped out
by pooches and weird sounds and they
probably say that they had an app with a
better virtual pet on their phones dear
diary now this gadget was something
every girl wanted to use for her secrets
dear diary was a total success in the
90s this pink toy was almost a tablet it
came with tons of different functions
and she were even able to read
horoscopes or even use it as a
calculator and the best part was you
could set up a password to keep it
locked and safe from any unwanted guests
with newer technology like iPhones iPads
are even any other tablets we have a
feeling dear diary would be totally
forgotten but to the 90s kids it was one
of the best futuristic gadgets ever
fisher-price rollerskates
have you ever had a chance to use
fisher-price rollerskates it's the color
palette 90s kids definitely remember
sure they might look clunky now but
these are one of the first toys that
actually taught us how to balance
ourselves on wheels and become pros at
skating you just strap them on your feet
and you were pretty much ready to go
but unfortunately kids today have things
like hoverboards to keep them
entertained and
however the best thing about these was
that they didn't even need to use any
kinds of batteries you just put them on
and go play school tape recorder and so
you can possibly forget about the play
school tape recorder this colorful toy
was the perfect karaoke machine and it
even allowed you to record your own
voice and play it back all you needed
was a tape and you were ready to go we
begged kids today wouldn't even know
what to do with an old-school tape when
many of them don't even have to use CDs
to play school recorder allowed us to
have our own portable radio and listen
to whatever we wanted but who needs that
when you have iTunes YouTube and Spotify
to listen to admit it how many kids
actually know what to do with play
school reporters tapes Gameboy and last
but definitely not least it's a gadget
that started the video game obsession
for many kids today can easily play with
apps on their phone but back then many
of us played with Gameboy you had to
purchase individual games and slide the
tape in the back to turn it on it's how
we entered the world of Pokemon and many
other games that are now available on
Xbox and other devices the Gameboy was
the best portable gaming device
available in the 90s it came in several
different colors and it provided us with
endless entertainment of course we all
also remember having to blow on the tape
to actually make it work and using an
extra light to play it in the dark kids
today definitely can't relate and that's
it for our video for more videos like
this one check out 10 toys that weren't
supposed to be for kids
[Music]